just like with a superhero batman we've
seen quite a few versions of catwoman
also known as selena kyle over the years
from julie newmar and arthur kit in the
batman tv series starring adam west and
burt ward to michelle pfeiffer and anne
hathaway in more modern film adaptations
there have been many changes to the
character over time so when it was
announced as zoe kravitz would be taking
on the iconic character for the new the
batman movie fans should have known to
expect something new in the batman fans
get to see a younger bruce wayne played
by robert pattinson in his early years
as a vigilante and that's the same case
with selena she isn't quite catwoman yet
though she's well on her way while she
has all of the skills and the drive to
become the well-known anti-hero she's
still just a young woman with some
personal issues to take care of but what
else does a 2022 film change about
selena while there are a few stark
changes for the character to know with
kravitz's performance there's one
glaring difference that drives the whole
movie forward beware spoilers ahead in
the original dc catwoman comics selena's
parents are maria and brian kyle who
both tragically die when she is quite
young leading to her life on the street
but the version of selena we see in the
batman doesn't quite have the same
experience yes her mother is maria but
her father is someone very different
it's noted by many that the comics
include speculation that selena's real
parents aren't the kyles but are really
carmine falcone and his wife louisa
while the comics never explicitly
confirm or deny this the batman decides
to concretely change the story and have
falcone be selena's father in the movie
maria works at the iceberg lounge and
has a relationship of sorts with a mob
boss which results in selena's birth
there is zero mention of her comic book
father brian and it seems unlikely that
there ever would be impossible future
films selena is completely sure that
falcone is her father but after being
abandoned by him after her mother's
death which she later finds out as his
doing she has no real attachment to the
man though she holds strong feelings of
resentment and anger so when bruce
uncovers the true death of falcone's
crimes selena is ever so eager to find
falcone and take him down stopping him
from doing anything else while also
getting a chance to confront him about
her mother add to that they reveal that
he's involved in her roommate's death
and you've got just about the worst
father-daughter relationship out there
but aside from the connection with
falcone the batman also makes one other
small yet important change to selena
while this is a very small detail in the
movie longtime fans of catwoman in the
dc comics might notice something about
the way selena interacts with her
roommate and co-worker from the iceberg
lounge the detail is actually a change
from past screen depictions of selena
but it makes the character more similar
to the comic book version luckily for
those who missed it matt galea of
pedestrian did not picking up on hints
of an intimate relationship between the
two women especially in how selena calls
her baby selena is frequently depicted
as bisexual in the comics which has made
canon in catwoman issue 39 so while the
batman definitely doesn't confirm
selena's sexuality there are hints that
this aspect of the character may be
explored in further films galia was able
to ask both kravitz and director matt
reeves about this specific detail
directly and whether or not it was a
purposeful choice in order to highlight
her bisexuality in the comics kravitz
confirmed to galea for pedestrian that
although it wasn't in the script that's
definitely the way i interpreted that
that they had some kind of romantic
relationship reeves wasn't as definitive
with his comments but he did say that i
don't think we meant to go directly in
that way but you can interpret it that
way for sure there was meant to be quite
an intimate relationship between them
based on this it's certainly worth
hoping that if reeves kravitz and others
return for future installments after the
batman selena's sexuality will finally
be accurately presented on screen check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
batman are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one